major major theme of the Donald Trump
campaign was globalism or as Alex Jones
like to say globalism uh the trumpets
the Infowars crowd the Alex Jones types
we must protect ourselves from the
globalist who believe in stuff like
world government and that globalism in
good is good and of course globalism
defined is a geopolitical policy where
the entire world is seen as the
appropriate sphere for a state's
influence and this includes the
development of social cultural tech or
economic networks that cross national
boundaries right-wingers supposedly are
against globalism they are for the u.s.
in contrast to every other country this
was one of the main fear-mongering
techniques of many pro-trump right-wing
media outlets Alex Jones has been
screaming about globalist for years and
years
trumpets voted Trump because he wouldn't
be like the globalist he was going to
put America first except now Trump is
filling his cabinet and advisory
positions with the same so-called
globalists that I thought were bad
during the campaign we've got Rex
Tillerson the CEO of a global oil and
gas company there is nothing more
globalist than that you've got Goldman
Sachs's Gary Cohen who's going to head
up the Economic Council
you've got Steve minuchin who is going
to head the Treasury Department and
you've got Anthony scaramouche II from
Goldman Sachs who's a key Trump
transition member what is more globalist
than Goldman Sachs and remember Trump
criticizing Hillary Clinton's ties to
Wall Street and her speeches now Trump
is hiring all the people Hillary gave
the speeches to and then of course
you've got Wilbur Ross is going to be
Trump's Commerce Secretary guys worth
nearly three billion dollars made a ton
of money buying companies and sending
jobs to Mexico there's no bigger
globalist pack than Wilbur Ross yeah
this really just goes to the idea that
Alex Jones is playing a character and at
some point he's going to have to flip
the script on Trump because his whole
thing is being against
status-quo whether it's democratic or
republican yeah just hasn't come around
to that yet yeah I was talking to some
people the other day who said you know
Alex Jones when Trump was the guy trying
to get elected it made sense for Jones's
narrative to be rah rah rah Pro Trump
but at some point is gonna have to go
against Trump and and by the way I
forgot to mention Rick Perry is going to
be Secretary of Energy Breitbart and
Alex Jones have been pushing the whole
Rick Perry is a globalist thing for
years these Republicans these trumpets
they care more about the fact that
Democrats lost rather than what Trump is
going to do because Trump is going to do
terrible things that even they claim to
be against during the campaign and again
Trump slammed Hillary's speeches and is
now filling his cabinet with the people
that paid hillary clinton to give the
speeches if you think i'm talking
nonsense here is anthony scaramouche II
one of the goldman sachs buffoons i
mention who's on trump's transition team
he went on MSNBC with chris hayes and
said uh we need to protect globalism
we're going to have a great relationship
with china okay all the president-elect
is saying is that we've got to create
fairness in that relationship and i said
something recently to one of the
sovereign wealth fund people that came
in at the end of the day the last hope
for globalism is that we fix the problem
in the middle class and a working class
of the united states and you and i have
talked about that we fix that problem
and we create a redo on that burgeoning
market of consumption are that's gonna
be phenomenal for china and for the rest
of the world and so we would have a
great relationship with china as we do
with all the other nation yet the last
hope for globalism globalism is good we
need trump to save globalism but wait a
second alex jones and all those types
are against globalism but they're for
trump but it's clearer and clearer that
there is no bigger globalist than Trump
and that's because it is all a farce
Trump attacks globalism during the
campaign here is a tweet that Donald
Trump published Hillary says things
can't change I say they have to change
it's a choice between Americanism and
her corrupt globalism and this is
effective because it evokes terrible
imagery of shuttered factories and
out-of-control undocumented immigration
and some kind of worldwide cabal that
controls everyone's lives oh and by the
way the entire way in which Trump
slammed globalism had serious
anti-semitic appeal as the
anti-defamation league pointed out just
replacing the word Jews with globalists
people voted it worked and now the
globalist in chief is coming to town and
the trumpets don't even know enough to
say I don't like this